i hear you're on the board of this
incredible institution i also heard you
guys donated the balcony
we didn't get to choose where the um but
yes aegis was like no i promise you
it'll be beautiful and i was like oh
great we like we thought it was gonna be
like a research center and they're like
no no you guys get the balcony that's
where the party is you know it's amazing
i know it's beautiful no we're i love
david agus and i think that everything
that they're doing is i mean this is
like you know going into circles but i
think it's incredibly important and
amazing i mean you guys do give back so
much and you also do such incredible
work with trafficking
how much do you talk about that in your
own house like how is that something you
want to instill in your kids one day
that giving back spirit
i mean i think that hopefully you lead
by example so it's we don't necessarily
talk about it but maybe that's not
really true because we have to go to
things like this and
when it comes to thorn
um
it's hard to to talk to a seven and a
five year old about the the purpose of
thorn but i think we talk about like
mommy and daddy try to help people so i
guess we do talk about that but maybe
not in in in detail yeah it's tonight a
bit of a date night for you you get out
of the house a little bit together
barely he just wrapped for the day and
then he came and picked me up so he's
like half in costume clothing half in
real clothing meanwhile i was like i got
time to put on his suit it's fine well i
know he's got uh vengeance right and you
have luckiest girl alive yes and then
he's shooting um
something right now with reese
witherspoon and it's gonna be awesome
but i don't oh my place are yours your
place for mine there's some version of
that it's gonna be great um but yeah
luckiest girl we wrapped uh
two weeks ago three weeks ago so first i
love the book i'm so excited for it but
how do you guys handle all that when
you're both so busy and you're doing
charity work and you got the kids what's
the protocol
tag team like i'll tell you we never
work at the same time
and um and i only or we only shoot on
location during summer breaks and then
the rest of the time we shoot at home
perfect you tag team the center
i know i know i was like you don't have
to talk he's been talking all day i was
like it's fine i'll do it um i'm sure
you're you're sick of talking about but
if you want to do another 10 minutes on
the bath debate
i mean
i refuse to i'm now literally gonna be
like no comment
were you surprised by the reaction how
many people weighed in like cardi b
weighed in the rock weighed in i don't
think i'm aware of how many people
weighed in i was in a different country
when in this one this
storm hit bleep it out a few months i
know i know you can um uh but i um it
didn't i didn't i don't think that i was
aware
honestly of what was happening with
but it's great listen if it gets
people's mind off of reality who cares
honestly thank you for that yeah
whatever people may laugh
that's great
so well what is also getting back to
this institution i think the thing i
sense right away from walking in is it
is changing the reality like you think
of cancer you think of hospitals you
think of pain and this center feels so
different was that part of why you
wanted to get so invested what do you
love about it it's david a yes honestly
like i think that his ethos as a doctor
in his bedside manner and the way that
he
makes everybody feel comfortable i mean
he's my general doctor i'd say so i got
really lucky in this case and that's
kind of how he got involved in all this
is he's
hands down the smartest person i ever
met and he just wants people to be okay
like there's no god complex behind it
there's no ego behind it he just he
believes in it and he wants everyone to
feel safe and comfortable
and so i i guess we
i guess believe in that more than
anything
i'll let you go unless thank you
anything you can tell me about leslie
[Music]
uh it's gonna be great
it's gonna be the heat of the summer